[Music]  trees and forests are true allies in the  fight against the climate and  biodiversity crises  trees purify our air  cool our cities and take up co2  we need to be their allies too  europe must step up its efforts to hold  deforestation  our new proposal will ensure that  relevant commodities and products are  not placed or made available on the  union market nor exported from the union  market unless they are deforestation  free  and we will work with other consumer  markets so that they join our efforts  we aim to reduce greenhouse gas  emissions and global biodiversity loss  promoting sustainable production and  consumption patterns  in the eu and globally  at the end of the day we're all part of  nature  what we do to fight the climate and  biodiversity crises we do for our own  health and our own future  you